that is the winning attitude that fans
love to see and rocky is live at stadium
swim at the circa hotel and casino
as fans arrive in preparation for game
two tonight
hey rocky
hey hey jc yeah we are at stadium can
you just take a look
at this place it is poppin already the
game is not till
seven and people are already here
getting their cabanas and their spots
ready i'm here with matt who
who is actually a local las vegas
so what are you doing at stadium swim i
thought this was just for tourists
oh no we come here too because there's a
big screen i don't know if you've
noticed
yeah we like to watch hockey we like to
do everything that's why i love circa
because it is for tourists and for
locals
so let's talk matt okay you
are a night's fan correct absolutely
what is your game day ritual oh wait
first i wake up in the morning
i eat a golden knights sandwich
and then after that we think about the
game
before it happens and then we all gather
up and we have a bunch of drinks
and then we go out and we watch the game
wow so this is like a pregame for you
guys
yes it says wow so where are you going
to watch tonight i'm going to watch it
at home tonight
okay that's nice that's nice and
wholesome we're gonna barbecue we're
gonna have a good time it's gonna be
amazing
that's pretty cool and now our my other
co-host mercedes she played a game
called the emoji game
but i have i'm gonna mix it up with you
okay we're gonna play
the spelling cup not stanley cup the
spelling cup you see what i did there
yes the spelling cup i see that yeah
he's a comedian by the way he's a
stand-up comedian so i feel like
you're if you give me props on that it's
it means something that's very
i give you lots of props on that all
right so you ready
yes all right knights fan you say you're
a knights fan
but can you spell can you spell max
pacharetti's last name max patretti's
p-a-t c-h
ready whoa no
you are way off i think you know that it
is
t t p-a-c-i-o-r-e-t-t-y and also by the
way max pacioretty's nickname is
wolverine do you know why
why is that because he has these magical
healing powers his friends and family
say
and also he eats a lot wow that's
amazing
so he just like regrows back all of his
energy injuries
we're not starting that rumor here but
let's just say he has really crazy
recovery powers that is amazing and i've
i've seen that you've seen her yes i see
that yeah resilient and we want to we
want to see if he actually plays tonight
because he's a game day decision
by the team they said that today so
we'll see if he actually thinks the bets
are going to
go again like that's going to be a big
betting factor correct
okay oh so i got a stand-up comedian and
an expert
thank you all right next question
william carlson now it sounds easy it
sounds easy right william carlson
but how do you spell carlson c-a-r-l
how that's so basic no no
it's k-a-r-l s-s
double s o n i know you would know
s's that's not even right they shouldn't
be doing that
i know it's crazy but here's the
question for william so
what ice cream what ice cream does he
call himself
oh um i know this one hurry we got a
wrap
the banana split no vanilla
because he's a quiet guy he's got a
low-key presence
unlike you you're more of a you're more
of a rainbow sorbet so
i'm kind of vanilla i'll send it back to
you guys check out the
nice game at seven maybe we should have
stuck with like mark stone
maybe that one s-t-o-n-e we want to know
what are your predictions for tonight's
game get connected with las vegas now
and share your answer
we are on all social media platforms all
you got to do is search
las vegas now all right we're keeping